let's get on with this
maybe oh my God maybe it's just cerebro
would that be great or maybe it's just
like a pocket reality maybe it's the
metaverse that she's going into this is
the Oculus
I don't think so but this is exactly
what we all feel when we go into the
metaverse I would imagine whenever I see
a Charlie Pooh concert in the metaphors
oh my god well the sounds of children
dies on not to the jam you would think
oh God and that cuts through that cut
the Cutaway is the most upsetting point
I don't know what they were expecting
yeah the tortuous prison yeah
with no guards very barely any staffing
it's like yeah this is uh you're all
sentenced to death in your own ways here
it's like many a Hollywood auditions
it's like who is running this right now
right the floor hurts yeah it's it's
kind of like when and you do a
commercial audition and then the guy
running camera goes and auditions
himself you're like wait is this you're
the camera and then he's then he's in
the commercials did I ever have a chance
yeah Aquino that's right he's he's a
member of the rebellions
any circus what a star what a snack they
should have put him in the trailers for
this maybe I mean any circus huge Star
right he's like uh he's obvious I would
say a big star then and also pretty
massive director too yeah I mean on
screen on screen the guy can do no wrong
hey welcome back to New Rockstar Star
Wars Andor says the very worst thing you
can do right now is bore me and damn did
they mean it new depths of torture and a
daring prison escape coming next episode
but how are they gonna do this well
you'll get your answers when you fix
this and door yeah we finally nailed it
we nailed it this had to be in person
this we had to do it in person because
you know Zoom was really the barrier
there Zoom was just trying to destroy
our chemistry but not today this is
WikiLeaks it's our weekly and or after
show this week we are here in New
Rockstar's HQ because you know they got
the leftover Halloween candy here and uh
my wife will not bring home any candy
from her office and I want here I I you
can get me to move mountains just to get
a little tiny box of dots that's right
you I think actually feel tackled by
producer John for for like a little
sleeve of Whoppers yeah and it wasn't I
think it was it was he was just picking
up trash yeah it was a rat it was a
Whoppers wrapper but you're like I like
to lick the glaze this is what you said
and I whispered that in his ear he
didn't know what I was referring anyway
he's gonna be out this week There's a
lawsuit pending and I'm gonna fight it
yeah I think we've got a good case I'll
testify against him uh well again
welcome back to WikiLeaks I'm Eric Boss
my Easter egg breakdown for this episode
of Andor is coming tomorrow right here
right now I'm here discussing this
episode with Tommy bechtold Tommy
General thoughts from this episode wow
what an episode we got to really see the
uh the turn from when uh the Empire is
just working amongst themselves to when
they're really getting into those Rebels
uh and we also got to see what I like a
good old-fashioned shot Shank Redemption
uh style prison breakout which I thought
was very enjoyable but let's get into it
let's see what happens this episode our
friend Bix is in deep deep
chicks right now okay she's got Mira or
Deidre Mira coming to question her uh
Mira seems very brutal she's excited to
introduce creepy doctor what's a great
pastime of any good science fiction
fantasy you gotta have a doctor that
looks like he's never kissed a girl
that's not a knock if you've never kiss
the girl that's fine but if you've never
kissed a girl and you're in your
reaction to that is to make a torturous
Oculus Rift helmet that's where the
problem is so there that's what the
problem is because I have so many
helmets and I I thought that I was not
the problem I thought everyone else is
there I'm sorry you are the problem Eric
but that doesn't mean you're not my
still my special beautiful boy and that
I'll Always Love You So we see Bix a
shell of herself after listening to the
children of what was that race again the
daisons no that's a type of fruit hold
on it was dysonite but it was from the
Moon called daison Frey ah yes we see
and they've isolated specifically the
children's tones this is um you know the
the Kidz Bop torture right they're just
making kids covers of these yeah oh my
God they're like from the top make it
drop that's a Dyson screaming at its
last thoughts I want to hear a group of
children singing Big Dick Energy oh yeah
it's in the works right now hey you know
that big energy they use this as actual
torture I think by this not in this
music and per se but they will use like
kids songs they'll use like happy music
as like CIA torture yeah like it's a
real thing that happens you know what
else is the real thing that happened in
this episode Miro goes from like you
know overzealous empirical up-and-comer
to uh why are we saying empirical I
think she's empirical she uses past
experience Empire or Imperial uh officer
to like actual Nazi here like this is
where she gets into like torture I mean
it's even a kind of a tone change that
scowl face that has been so perfect now
becomes so menacing and evil when she's
hurting our dear picks who we love so
much and we know miros miro's Quest is
she wants and or she wants Cassian and
she also wants the name of the
mysterious buyer that they have
nicknamed uh axis right and they know
that Bix is the only one who's used the
secret radio so back on Coruscant just
around the corner from her own office uh
she's still struggling in the scent
there's a lot of heckling this felt like
the British Parliament where they're
like just making fun of each other and
like turning around and like flipping up
their coattails
these parliamentary procedure that I
honestly I would say I wish our Congress
uh did but I think there's kind of like
an unspoken just nature too like they
all respect each other yeah maybe not
right now in the British Parliament but
our Congress ours is just like Lauren
bobert being like you know read right my
husband showed his balls to girls at a
bowling alley anyway we can cut that if
you want keep it in all right so
Monmouth we get it revealed when we were
questioning who's vel's rich family it's
the mothmus she's always been a mothma
she's a Mothman girl in a Mothman World
guys but and mod bags are to just be a
spoiled little rich girl for a while
keep her cover because we forget Val has
been in the Rebellion with Lutheran
carrying out missions falling in love
with Sinta Hearts breaking hearts Aiken
but now mothman's like you know just go
shopping go to space Gucci for a while
get a few purses have your credit card
get rejected angrily call your mom
something along those lines make sure
someone's got their camera out recorded
do it for the Instagram yeah I like that
this is like both a message to her to
try to just stay out of it for a little
bit lay low but this is also like advice
it's basically what Luton would tell
someone like play this double part this
your job is not done just doing the
rebel missions just one half of the
mission right now in order to stay and
fight a new day you have to have another
identity there it's not we're not ready
to be full-blown Rebels out there the
only full-blown Rebel really is Cassie
and Andor yeah I guess saw Guerrera
there's other ones out there now we
catch up with my boy zero Karn uh let's
be honest this guy's a mess he's uh
having yet another succulent meal at his
mother's table well she berates him and
then he just does he does what we all
love when we're in trouble we've been
getting bad grades but we know we aced
the test he lets her finish and then I
was I was promoted and she's like all
forgiven my special little boy I thought
at first he was lying I thought he was
true I thought we were going to see him
go to like I think taste in front of the
ISB every day uh trying to get a job I
mean that's how we both got hired that's
right we just walked in around we went
to our main offices in Calgary uh Dr
Monroe yes and we we paced in front we
were both wearing trench coats and it
and then we were wearing nude body suits
though was the weird thing so we kept
doing this but we weren't showing
anything and then we they brought us in
to audition and then we were the camera
operators yeah and that's where the
bodysuits really paid off so Cyril he's
got his mom she's impressed then he does
what all good uh great lovers in cinema
do he stalks the person he's interested
in stands in front of her prevents her
from walking her Pathway to where all of
this is creepy all this is what he's
talking about this is the chase oh my
God I can't but she doesn't know it well
I'll tell you what both zero Karn and
diedramiro took what I would call like
heel heel turns they were already heels
and then they just went they went a
layer they peeled a layer off the heel
onion today and we're like no we're
actually way way creepier than uh then
we were revealed to be before now one
person who's really doing his job right
and blending in is Cassian AKA Keith is
a model worker at nikina five they're
winning those extra bowls with flavor in
them they got flavor in their food now
okay it's like dominoes every five years
when they're like hey guys we realized
the last five years our pizza's been bad
but now it's good that's what they got
they have the good uh nakina five hose
meats or whatever they are that they
bring them in so they're building these
giant cogs and you can see that that
Cassian is working on an Escape Plan
he's now got some people who are clearly
in cahoots he's doing a little Shawshank
shaving of a pole in the bathroom I love
he's got to like pound out the little
panel he does like quick little Cuts
then they come back to the floor puts it
back in I hope by next time there's a
like uh
there's a mon mothma poster hanging over
it of her like in a bikini no oh come on
like Shawshank in their mind she's just
a senator who cares a bit too much about
the governments and everyone else in my
mind there's a mon mod get that out of
your mind Tommy speaking of which check
out new rockstarshop.com for mon mothma
bikini post no those aren't there uh and
that's not a merge plug all right now
Keith Kiff yet wait till the coaster set
comes up Kino Loi seems to be the key to
unlocking this whole plan but they're uh
you know he's Andy Circus he's still
pissed off you know I thought that like
uh Cassian was an Institutional man
because in that opening scene he's like
we're gonna get ahead we're going to get
ahead of everyone else we're so close
we're so close and he's like sure it was
nice that he was covering for the old
for ooloff but uh it seemed like he was
like competitive but again you said like
cassian's the one who's not playing
double roles I think he is playing a
double role in that regard he's playing
the role of like an honest hard-working
prisoner when in reality he's still
working to try to get out he's clocking
the guards yeah you're right he's
clocking what things are electrified
what aren't like he is perfectly playing
the part I think of what the rebel
Rebels need to do right now that's a
good point and it seems like only Kino
Loy AKA Andy Circus can can really help
them genuinely uh uh hatch an effective
Escape Plan uh but he ain't doing it
until off dies for ooloff he was
struggling so bad first of all one quick
Tony Gilroy don't at me and I'm sorry I
love you I love everything you're doing
with this show the entire basis of this
prison is that these people are seen as
physically fit to work unless uloff got
in 89 years ago I think that was the
implication I think this which is scary
that this prison existed during the
Republic area but you know that tells
everything you need to know about the
Republic they weren't perfect either so
this I think this prison to be this well
executed and well oiled and you could
argue it's not that well oiled it's more
the design the Opticon design of it that
makes it as effective as it is right I
think this has existed pre-empire I
think there was some freaking super
villain creeper who's like ooh now it's
a now it's a fascist Empire why don't I
bring my pitch to them when in the
meantime he was probably he was probably
a private prison contractor who was
selling this to the highest bidder
during the Republic era which is
terrifying terrifying terrifying well
rest in power Rest in paradise Olaf he
dies and that is the spark that is gonna
get uh that is gonna get old Kino on our
side here because the doctor who comes
to treat uloff reveals that the rumors
about the a hundred men on what was it
sector two yes sector two which it's 50
per ship that means both sides of it it
was it wasn't the the shift it was
during the bridge transition that the
shift trade-off and then just that's
when everyone can kind of talk that's
like in between the classes when like in
fifth grade we had five b and 5A when
you're in between classes and you
switched with the kids who are in The
Accelerated match right that's when
chaos Reigns that's when we used to the
floors used to vibrate in my school and
we don't we'd all be shocked they'd be
like all right now you go in and learn
about hexagons and I go
all right anyway they they found out
that basically in sector two they're
recycling in the inmates once you're
getting processed out you're just
getting putting in you're getting put
into a new section There Is No Escape
there is only work work is life life is
work work till death death is released
death is the only Freedom now I'm on
board that means our boy Kino has
officially become part of the Rebellion
so we can believe next week the Escape
here's hoping well can I ask you Tommy
is it possible that our man uloff was
one of those recycled prisoners yeah and
he was just so institutionalized he
didn't want to live on the outside he's
like you know I kind of like this system
of hustling to make these weird racks
and cogs and we don't know what they are
but it's better than what I had before
and that's why you so old he was just a
guy who like did have a prison sentence
but then they just kind of reset the
shot clock so he was back on another
level and you just never said anything
or is it just the Classic prisoner
conditioning of like they broken right
like the first two times they were
bribing him because like right you know
you could this works if you're you know
you let the guy out and like on the way
out you're like well
if you go down and work for us on
another sector for a brief amount of
time we will you know give you special
we'll give you more we'll give you money
upon your lease we'll pay you or you
think they were sneaking marshmallows in
his meat too and that exactly he was
getting he was getting some marshmallows
in that cocoa meat hose but uh that
cocoa meat host Coco was the name of uh
no man I know Myrtle Beach
I think that's a that's a bang Bros some
Channel subscription
man he was a fire hydrant anyway uh so
let me put it to you this way I think
you're right I think Olaf had been
cycled enough but I think by the time
they got him he was just brain scrambled
he's like I just love making these
chassis these Death Star chassis or
whatever probably and uh like can we
just like give a shout out to
Christopher Fairbank how amazing this is
the guy who said what are you to Michael
Keaton to imprompt the responsive I'm
Batman yeah this is also the guy in
Guardians of the Galaxy he was the
antique shop he was the Lutheran of
xandar yeah yes a fantastic character
actor and uh you know we he's an older
actor we don't give older actors enough
credit when they play like feeble dying
characters yeah it is it's it's not an
easy thing to pull off uh and he was it
was sad to see him go 100 100 and and
and uh yeah uh sorry my brain completely
farted there it's okay you're thinking
about cocoa meat I'm thinking about
cocoa Meat House I'm thinking about them
too I was thinking about giving the
older actors there too oh yes what an
embarrassment of riches this show is
with the casting we have people doing
you know two episode arcs on the show
that are phenomenal actors Tony Gilroy
you've blessed us once again thank you
everybody get on this show tell your
friends if you're watching Wikileaks
right now and you got a friend who's
like ah I'm more of a Wookie freak out
in the streets get them out here and
tell them to watch the show all right
leave some of those freaks on it on the
street is what I say that's true and I
think again we had another Chernobyl
actor I might be wrong I need to double
check but I think the the med tech guy
the end what played for me in uh in
Chernobyl we now have like four or five
of them in this show let's get let's get
uh everybody in there let's get Jared
Harris yes oh Jared Harris he he would
fit perfectly on this show he just be
watching his wife's stand-up shows in
the valley right now is that a thing yes
his wife is a stand-up comic and she
used to host an open mic at the oyster
house and he would come and support it
was so sweet but you're like holy [ __ ]
Jared Harris is here I kind of want to
talk to him I kind of want to see him do
some stand-up I think he'd be great
um okay let's talk about next episode
how will Andor escape the narkina 5
Prison who's gonna survive we know for
sure that melshi and Andor are going to
survive now I'm wondering about Keno I
think it's gonna be hard for Andy Circus
to stay alive in in the Star Wars
universe or to have any future knowing
that he also plays snoke who I think
would be alive at this time snoke's not
going to show up on this show right uh
but I think it's hard for snoke would be
alive at this time I think so I think
he's old enough the guy's super old I
think he was around during the Galactic
Civil War oh interesting I just in my
scrambled brain and not knowing enough
of the extended Universe I always was
like oh no uh Palpatine was just growing
them in a hose to be old boy The Meat
House Coco meat hoes Coco meat host was
growing him over on Mexico
um so I was trying I was playing the
game that Lutheran was playing this
episode not Luther well I'm always
playing the game Lutheran plays you know
I just like to show off all my toys and
really we've got some fancy daggers in
the shop this week oh you want to look
at my coins it's the Prince of Persia
dagger Easter egg is Prince of purge a
Star Wars cannon no no not yet but you
know other lucasfilm stuff is like a
Indiana Jones Willow probably hey but
let's let's uh what Cassie was doing
right he was identifying which parts of
this prison are actually actually
electrified we are we know that he
already knows where the boots are kept
and now he knows how many guards per
level 50 per level no more than 50 which
means it's probably less while other
guards are being are transferring other
prisoners they can probably time this
perfectly and all they gotta do is get a
hold of one set of boots yeah one set of
boots and one cattle prod and you're
good you can overwhelm the rest of them
because then just tackle them push their
face into the floor and there's no way
they're gonna Electrify it that's right
because they're gonna be like oh well
I'm gonna be shocking my friend unless
they really hate their co-workers right
I mean here at new rockstars that is uh
that's a risk that you write never more
than 12. never more than 12. not 50.
never more than two well that's what I
mean there's 50 prisoners
so what I'm saying is get a hold of one
set of boots tackle a few more of them
push their faces into the floor so you
know that's going to kill them
immediately if you do and then just leap
Lily Pad Lily Pad just scooch one down
all you need are two you just step on
one put scoot the other one down jump to
the other one drag the other one behind
you sling them past you and just Lily
Pad your way out to that fresh air what
an adorable adorable Escape yeah where
they're all just
did you just leapfrogging over each
other I mean it's like floor is lava
yeah we used to play this game all the
time I still play it I haven't touched
the floor of new Rockstar's offices in
three years I guess it's really
inconvenient because they make people
carry well we love to do it it's our
pleasure all right here's what I'm
thinking Kino unfortunately made the TV
and movie sin of saying what what do we
say I've got two months left in here
you don't say that I'm one day away from
retirement in five days my pension kicks
in uh I'm going to get my mail order
bride from Russia in three weeks those
are death sentences in my world okay do
you think like I've got a reservation at
Popeye's for my birthday that you're
dead for sure before then
I wonder if they're gonna have to wait
for one of these prisoner transports to
come in like if they're gonna just have
to wait how often are prisoners coming
in really basically there's the like
suction whirlpools all around right and
what do we think those suction
whirlpools all are you had the theory
that they were like sarlax or hydra's
type or they're just like uh mechanical
things that like will suck you down so
it's hard to swim away I think these are
propulsion engines they're propellers
that keep it afloat because oh yeah it's
hard a metal facility how is that
buoyant is my question like we had the
raft prison in the MCU that I think was
supposed to I don't think it was was it
bobbing it didn't look like it was
affected by the ocean waves in Civil War
my theory is that like there's something
that connects all the way to the C
bottom that keeps it like sturdy they
keep I mean we know Iron Man loves his
uh undersea diving when he hooked up
that power cable to New York I that's
what I think normally these things would
have to do you'd have to Anchor them so
the fact that something I don't imagine
this would be buoyant at all they have
to find some kind of way and my theory
is that if they these are not cogs if
these are not cogs of the Death Star I
get that that makes the most sense
that's what they're building down there
these are just pieces of a machine just
to keep this thing afloat which is the
cruelest thing in some ways that's
cooler than the desk yeah like it's
we're literally it's like the uh
Perpetual uh LA or gloss or California
highway department projects where
they're like they're just fixing the
roads all the way down and then as soon
as they reach the end they start fixing
them back up it's a loop it's a loop I
mean every all of life is just a loop of
inefficiency or a perfectly efficient
Loop in which no progress is ever made
and as I always say in the end
it's only Darkness
but what sweet relief that darkness is
uh because imagine Darkness unless it
has the screams of dysonite children
[Music]
right that's as long as it's not
screaming mama
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and now I get the rest of the day off
um so I think let's let's play some bets
right now let's uh we know melshi we
know Ander is going to survive well
anyone else from this prison make it out
I got a bad feeling just based on
andorra's ability to move around in
Rogue one not a lot of the people from
his past are alive it just makes that
that kind of sense to me also
I don't I mean Andor is fresh
you know he's in like he's he's just a
tourist he just got in there I mean I
mean we know sometime has passed do we
think he's still telling everyone in the
prison of just the tourists I'm Maddie
didn't say it in this episode because
it's my favorite thing but uh I think
unfortunately there are going to be some
people who want to escape that don't
quite have it in him to escape I think
there's gonna be more people who want to
stay yeah I think that's going to be the
the horrible cynical truth of this is
that they've so much people who don't
believe that they're gonna have a tough
time convincing them that that a
thousand people died because of a riot
or a hundred people died because of a
riot yeah and more likely that just
something they were punished for doing
something bad I think I think Kino's
gonna die yeah uh I think the med tech
is gonna die yeah I think taga has a
pretty good chance yeah talk is a young
guy bright future ahead of him and it
seems like there's some loyalty Forge
between him and Keith girgo the tourist
yeah who who covered for him and they
gave him the idea and I think the other
guy he was talking to after he came out
of the bathroom I think that guy yeah
yeah too yeah yeah uh no women at this
prison it's a male prison system all the
women are at the wobani prison with
Jennifer so is she there now do we know
if she's there now or she hasn't gotten
in prison yet we don't know how long she
was in there for I have to re-watch
Rogue one I'm too busy re-watching the
MCU right now in anticipation for black
panther that's another property it is a
different property well uh before we
continue to talk about this episode we
want to thank some friends who helped us
make it thank you to wondery for
sponsoring this episode go deeper into
the canals of numenor the minds of kazak
Doom and more with the official the Lord
of the Rings the rings of power podcast
host Felicia Day and several special
guests provide an inside look at the
groundbreaking series and what it took
to bring Middle Earth to life each
episode of the official podcast features
exclusive interviews with the series
showrunners JD Payne and Patrick McKay
including the very first breakdown of
the incredible season finale Felicia
also goes behind the scenes with the
cast and crew to bring you jaw-dropping
stories and Easter eggs you won't want
to miss watch the rings of power on
Prime video and listen to all eight
episodes of the official the Lord of the
Rings the rings of power podcast for
free on Amazon music download the Amazon
music app now God I need it I need
supplementary material I read The Hobbit
this is one of the first books I read in
third grade with my mom when I had the
flu and thank God it had pictures it was
one that had like it was a picture
Edition I still am trying to find it on
Amazon it was a large Green version of
it anybody know call in uh anyway uh
this is a phone we'll pick it up if it
rings no one's called yet all right
let's continue to talk about this
episode they seem to be I was a little
confused by the structure of this
because it seemed up until this point at
least the first six episodes there was a
three episode Arc and another three
episode Arc and then we had episode
seven which is kind of a transitional
episode I thought was gonna be part of
the next three episode Arc so I thought
this episode was gonna be the prison
break that's probably the next episode
so that leaves I believe what two
episodes right on the other end of it
that'll probably be our finale or do you
think it'll take three episodes to break
out of prison probably not I hope not
because I think that there's I think we
need to push and or further along out as
an independent operative by the end of
this because we know that this this is
supposed to be the first year of his
store where we meet him in the in the
universe and then the next back half 12
episodes are the next four years leading
up to Rogue one so I think this has to I
think by the end he's basically
operating as a high-priced rebellion uh
Hired Gun right I thought that uh going
into this season that we'd see k2so by
the end of it um but there is a k2so
comic Canon that like showed how they
actually met right but we just saw in
the tales of the Jedi episodes uh well I
guess it's not spoiler warning at this
point by the time it's been out for
about a week watch tales of the Jedi
it's so good yeah I thought that was
incredible yeah I was completely blown
away uh how well put together that was I
was like it was like the vibe of the
final four episodes of Clone Wars season
seven how amazing that was same composer
it's still Dave filoni's Vision very
dark very Grim not a lot of dialogue
just kind of visual storytelling it's
just so beautifully done anyway one of
the things we we learned is that they
they kind of condense ahsoka's uh
timeline after Order 66 before she shows
back up as a fulcrum agent uh they
condense a lot of stuff from uh EK
Johnson's novel
um so I think we're seeing this weird
phase where the uh the stuff that we
thought about these characters backstory
from the literary material isn't beat
for beat exactly Canon uh if it's going
to be adapted in a different way so I
think this series is still open to adapt
k2so's origin story in a different way I
just think Tony Gilroy and other
producers have said he's not gonna show
up till season two right
um but we do have this hint at the
finale uh or at least the final few
episodes with this whole Anton Krieger
yeah and I forgot about that in the uh a
beginning summary my apologies that was
the one chunk I left out they've
captured a rebel they captured a rebel
pilot do you think this rebel pilot is
somewhat important what if it's wedge
Antilles
he I if they got wedged that'd be
impressive that he was able to get out
at that point for future they're like
kill him right they're not there can't
be that many Rebel Pilots at this point
in history I mean we saw two x-wings
with saw guerreras what else could it be
so not they don't have a huge Fleet of
wet x-wings to be a pilot what are they
piloting what if it's Perkins oh what if
it's pork I hope it's Porkins I would
love a porkin's origin story it's real
thin and then he gets real fat in prison
for some reason
I mean Perkins he's like my name is my
name is Jet slimkins and then when they
when he gets out they're like you're not
slimkins anymore and it's like so it's
like solo a Star Wars movie they're like
your name now is Jed
poor kid hey what if we find out his
name is Perkins because he's a butcher
like you know that butcher scene in the
Mandalorian episode of The Book of Boba
Fett what if the way he got out is
Perkins just wrecked everybody he walks
out just covered in blood and they're
like you're porkin's the butcher now or
what if we find out his name is poorkins
because he's got away with the ladies
Coco peep too
smoker unmask yourself cocoa beef cube
oh it's me Porkins sploosh
um all right speaking of sploosh oh wow
uh is that in Mandela yes it is and it's
something very offensive Dedra and Cyril
are they gonna are they gonna no don't
no I know they're leading us that way I
really hope not there's no need no she
doesn't need to fall for it he is too
much of a creep come on why can't the
good guys get the girl uh that's what
Cyril would say I'm a good guy why
doesn't she like me I found her to work
every day hoping to see her I grabbed
her arm and she tries to turn away from
me we both hate Cassian and she's like I
secretly love Cassie again you would I
always like the bad boys want to be
treated like [ __ ] I'm going on my
message boys [ __ ] Cassie and more like
Chad seeing I'm going on Jawa chant and
I'm gonna dox you uh I really hope I
hope it's unrequited I get that zero is
into Dedra I mean this is like the full
package okay yeah but dedra's got bigger
things to worry about than this little
piece of crap I think if she's into it
I'm gonna be a little bummed I don't
need this I mean it makes sense on a
certain level I just like don't want to
see it she's got higher Ambitions we've
got no need she's got no time for that
he's just gonna drag her down ain't
nobody got time isn't it weird that
we're rooting for Dedra to make smart
choices for herself this Nazi woman
[ __ ] really love yes she tortured
someone and man uh Denise Scott the
perfect sneer like how she could just
hold her face like that because that's
not her normal face it's it's kind of
like when we watch Tony Soprano uh uh
James Gandolfini I thought James
Gandolfini just talked like that yeah
that was the choice that he sustained
for several seven seasons and this is
what Denise Goff is doing in every seat
she's just incredible but uh yeah I'm
rooting for her I like efficiency I like
characters who uh go after what they
want and I like smart characters I don't
agree with her ambition so the end of
the day I don't want her to be
successful for the faith of the other
characters it's just yeah I mean come on
guys come on Empire let up a bit live a
little well let's live a little right
here in the final part of this after
show we talked about it earlier a
dysonite death cry they said they make a
this torture says they make a sound as
they die a sort of coral agonized
pleading and then they isolate the
children so let's uh we didn't hear it
we just saw uh Adriana's face Adriana
jarona's face what do you think was
playing on her ears
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that's beautiful what do you think I
would scream if I heard that especially
if it was real quiet
um I think it's the Star Wars equivalent
of the brown note oh so I think they
play the brown note and her screaming
there is Big [ __ ] herself it's just
[Music]
and she's like
that's why they had to drag her away
lifting up because [ __ ] yeah it's just
Stan Marsh just she's just making a pile
that's why they had to drag her right
away Tommy she [ __ ] her guts out and
they don't have dry cleaners
okay I heard a phone ringing hello
yes
oh I bet you had Samantha Tommy Tommy
someone found that green book for you
what my Hobbit green book is on its way
to you Rockstar Studios and Calgary
Calgary Canada reach out if you know
where it is I'll buy it from you thank
you bye well we'll leave it there for
this episode of WikiLeaks again might
we'll just let him take a nap okay
sometimes he likes to sleep he likes to
he's fully Pro that's like the snap snap
yeah snack snack snap wait snap nap at
nap why can't I talk it's news new um
but yeah my Easter egg breakdown is
coming out tomorrow to the channel you
can follow Tommy at Tommy bech told
follow me at eavos now we will not be
here next week uh reacting to the finale
or not the family episode 10 but
um but don't worry you're going to see a
lot more of me and Tommy here at
neuroxis and uh we're gonna find a way
to get our reactions into the breakdown
absolutely because you got to see me and
Tommy reacting to the most shocking
death screen whatever it is you worry
don't you worry follow new Rockstar
subscribe to WikiLeaks wherever you get
your podcast thank you so much for
watching and we have spoken